ganz ehrlich der rest ist für sie ein
herrlich
also sie geben ihm das ja okay und ob er
freut sich
sie können davon abhängt was geht ab und
jetzt bekommen bei einem neuen video ja
leute ich hoffe natürlich euch jetzt gut
ihr seht schon ich muss direkt schon
grinsen was ja eigentlich auch nur gutes
bedeuten kann leute heute habe ich mal
wieder was witziges vor
das wetter ist extrem heiß das heißt es
passt auch gut es dreht sich heute viele
zum eis habt ihr wahrscheinlich eurem
titel schon gelesen da ich nicht so bin
wie die meisten anderen deutschen
youtuber und das ja auch schon öfter
gesagt habe mir bleibt heute also
eigentlich gar keine andere wahl als zu
sagen leute das video heute ja ist
inspiriert aus amerika ich habe ja
wieder so einen coolen trend entdeckt
den ich gerne heute mal probieren möchte
hier in deutschland und ich bin mir
sicher dass spätestens in zwei tagen
irgendein anderer größerer youtube ein
video macht zumindest von der grundidee
her gleich ist ja auch gar nicht schlimm
ist wie gesagt ist nicht meine idee wäre
das jetzt erfunden hat weiß ich nicht um
ehrlich zu sein aber da gibt es schon
ein paar videos zu und ja wir sollten
mal werde übermorgen aus dem video in
deutschland bucht ist jetzt muss ich
aber natürlich erst mal erklären worum
es geht weil ich gehe davon aus dass die
meisten von euch gar keinen plan haben
und so habe ich mir für den ersten part
überlegt also wenn euch das gefällt dann
lasst auf jeden fall jetzt schon mal
doch nach oben dann mache ich das auch
noch mit anderen sachen ich kenne es
selber von früher das war so oft so ich
habe mir gedacht komm bestellst du dir
hier bei diesem fast food laden noch
einen ice zug und das kommt ja dann sehr
auf die antwort die eismaschine ist
kaputt ich denke es ist bei jedem von
euch auch schon mal passiert falls nicht
haben meiner meinung nach extrem ist
glück gehabt wäre es gerade 17 uhr und
oftmals passiert das so gegen 22 uhr
würde ich mal sagen wenn der laden und
24 uhr schließt das wenn nun alles
bestellst du kannst mehr bekommst weil
die eismaschine kaputt ist oder sie hat
keine lust mehr haben diese sauber zu
machen was ja auch an sich
verständliches ich meine ich will mich
da gar nicht groß zu war aufregende
heute ist allerdings dass wenn die
eismaschine funktioniert was ihr
hoffentlich soll bei diesem wetter habt
wenn dann überlegen ob ich jetzt
anfangen und dann heute abend nochmal
weitermache oder ob ich jetzt alles
durchziehen ich himmels gleich 100 euro
ab und immer wenn das
fast-food-restaurant
ich bin mir ein eis ausgeben kann oder
ausschenken her wie gesagt man überhaupt
auf jeden fall immer wenn ich zeit
bekommen hat kriegt die person am
schalter von mir geld und mal gucken wie
die reaktion
dann würde ich sagen wir lieber gar
nicht lange fahren direkt mal los ich
wünsche euch viel spaß mit dem video wie
gesagt geben doch nach oben für weitere
parks letzte bisschen scharf stellen
hier bitte danke
auf jeden fall würde ich sagen wir
fahren war so die übliche route am
nächsten hier ist ein mcdonald's
restaurant da stelle ich das erst danach
kommt burger king dann kommt wieder
mcdonald's dann kommt ein krebs wie ja
keine ahnung ob ich alles schaffe ich
hoffe es wird witzig ich werde natürlich
auch so ein bisschen mit dem
kommunizieren und ich würde ganz viel
spaß dabei ich bin vor sowas immer so
ein bisschen nervös weil ich immer angst
habe okay wie werden diese reaktion irrt
werden die lustig werden die langweilig
so das könnte ja denken verstehen so
leid ich weiß gerade auch bei der bank
und zwar haben wir hier geld abgeholt
ich habe jetzt 400 euro abgeholt in 20
euro scheinen das heißt ich weiß nich so
20 euro finde ich schon extrem viel geld
wenn man irgendwie arbeitet und einem
einer plötzlich 20 euro schenkt war da
würde ich mich selber richtig darüber
freuen ich finde man muss ja auch nicht
übertreiben und diese 10.000 euro videos
und deutschland sind erle click&buy also
hier habt ihr wirklich 100 euro ich
würde sagen geradeaus dann rechts und
dann bin ich auch schon beim ersten
laden ja losgeht so leute ich stehe
jetzt hier in der schlange mir ist
gerade eingefallen ich glaube die dürfen
gar kein trinkgeld oder kein geld was
man schenken möchte an zumindest habe
ich irgendwie im kopf dass ich
irgendwann mal das schon mal so machen
wollt oder dass ich halt irgendwie drei
augen trinkgeld geben wollte und die
beiden so sorry darf ich nicht annehmen
aber jetzt mal rein theoretisch wenn ich
dann einfach weiterfahren können ja
nichts machen so koopmann
hey funktioniert eure eis verschiedene
heute ja okay dann hätte ich gerne ein
mac sowie mit smarties also leute heute
ist wirklich ein glückstag bitteschön
das stimmt so ehrlich jetzt der rest ist
für dich nein ehrlich ich war ja schon
bei einem anderen und das problem ist
die hatten kein eis und jetzt habe ich
gedacht wenn ihr jetzt ein einzelner
abhängig den rest weil ich auch so ich
hab so bock auf ein eis nein nein ich
mache jetzt einfach das fenster hoch und
dann muss ich auch selber ein ich habe
jetzt einfach das fenster hoch gemacht
jetzt ist er weg gegangen
ich glaube er holt jetzt den chef oder
so leute ich weiß nicht ob ihr das sehen
können weil ich will auch nicht so die
mitarbeiter auf ihnen was sie mal blöd
wenn die kamera sehen weil dann werden
wir zu ich mir real weiße weil dann
checken die so okay das ist irgendwie
youtuber oder so ich fahre weiter vor
dann können wir nämlich gar nichts mehr
sagen du bist ja noch okay und jetzt
guck ich habe noch nicht mehr nach
hinten könnt ihr ihnen sehen ist er
wieder da
weiter weiter weiter ok mal gucken was
jetzt passiert
danke
schnell weg okay die frage ist verteilt
auch gesagt das ist zu viel das kann ich
nicht annehmen dann hab ich die scheibe
hof gemacht so das heißt er hat
angenommen gehe ich von haus und jetzt
habe ich hier das teuerste eis meines
lebens daher für 20 euro muss das ja
auch extrem gut schrecken ein euro weg
noch in euro also das war jetzt relativ
unspektakulär würde ich mal sagen
deswegen gefahren ist weiter ich würde
als nächstes mal irgendein anderes
restaurant auswählen wenn ich jetzt
gleich mal grün wird wahrscheinlich ist
sie wieder irgendein konzert heute oder
so also wollten wir sehen uns wieder im
nächsten wald wo auch immer das sein
wird ich habe keine ahnung den nächsten
stopp blicke ich hier mal bei k s hier
ein handy überhaupt
also ich bin mir gerade wirklich
unsicher ob die ice haben ich wäre jetzt
eigentlich auf schlagen auf die
eismaschine funktioniert und wenn die
kein eis haben kann ich dem auch kein
geld geben
das ist ja ganz klar nachher wir werden
mal sehen was passiert
ne na.de eismaschine wir haben gar kein
eismaschine alles klar kein problem
also ich glaube das wäre heute nichts
mehr hallo funktioniert ihre eismaschine
okay dann hätte ich gern so ein kleines
eis zu mitnehmen also
ach so sie haben wir können als
entschuldigung dann fahre ich weiter das
muss sie nicht okay dann nehme ich dann
einfach also das schmeckt dann so wenig
wie ein eis wahrscheinlich ja die nehme
ich einfach den kleinen also ich glaube
der ist korrekt erst jetzt bestimmt mal
gucken ob das an dem ich könnte jetzt
eigentlich das geld geben und wegfahren
oder sollte weil das ist sieger casey wo
ich mal nicht zahlen musste da haben
sich viele darüber aufgeregt ich hoffe
also ich kann euch hier die szene gerne
noch mal kurz einblenden deswegen
kriegen die jetzt einfach von mir das
geld und dann fahre ich einmal weg dann
müssen jetzt an den habe ich jetzt
überhaupt bezahlt ich habe gar nichts
bezahlt
er hat ja auch nichts
also soll ich wieder zurückfahren dach
kommen egal
nein danke stimmt so
trans haben ehrlich der rest ist für sie
ein herrlich richtig gefreut herkunft
du machst jetzt witzeln und jetzt habe
ich den sogar noch mehr geld
zurückgegeben heißt sie eigentlich von
mir noch hätten bekommen sollen also das
kann keiner von euch etwas sagen da
freue ich mich drüber wieder sich
gefreut hat ich weiß nicht ob ich das ob
ich ihn zensiere so ein bisschen
wahrscheinlich muss ich etwas nicht
macht aber falls du das gegen die seen
solltest danke dass du so bock auf
seinen job alles und so freundlich war
wollte ich mal kurz mehr loswerden jetzt
muss ich eigentlich mal kurz den
leckersten milchshake der soleg heißt
vielen leckeren eis probieren
ich weiß nicht also ich muss ganz
ehrlich sagen so ganz hat mich das jetzt
nicht um es ist lecker aber man kann es
trinken aber ganz normalen besseren
milch getrunken leute ein machen wir
noch und zwar burger king ja wir machen
auf jeden fall noch berg
was
alles klar noch gar nichts ich
funktioniere eismaschine dann ein als
also ich glaube die eismaschine
funktioniert doch nicht der rest ist für
den kollegen der ist nämlich so nett dem
schenke ich das heute dem land von geld
genau der der mich bleibt bedient hat
nein es wahrscheinlich ihm aber sagen
sie ihm dass erst gleich wenn ich weg
bin okay einfach so danke also sie geben
ihm das okay okay und ich hoffe ihr
freut sich sie können davon auch drei
euro
leute also diese reaktion die sind
wirklich zu genial das macht mich heute
so glücklich
also ich habe zwei leute wirklich
richtig glücklich gemacht das habe ich
gemerkt auf der von gerade der war erst
ein bisschen genervt weil das erste
funktioniert hat und wenn er jetzt von
seiner kollegin gesagt bekommt der hat
hier gerade einfach 18 euro geschenkt
dann ist ja bestimmt voll glücklich oder
und darum geht es ja auch an sich leute
schrieb auf jeden fall idee für weitere
parks in die kommentare was die leute
die dort arbeiten oder mich bedienen
erfüllen müssen damit sie von mir ein
bisschen geld kriegen um ihren tag halt
ein bisschen schöner zu machen oder dass
sie sich darüber freuen weil ich meine
mit diesem video wollte ich das sowieso
wieder raus und von daher ist das gar
kein problem mache ich gern so wir
fahren jetzt erst mal nach hause und
dann sehen wir uns zuhause ich bin
gespannt auf eure ideen schreibt jetzt
in die kommentare
daumen nach oben bis gleich das war's
mit dem video ich habe es schon fertig
geschnitten und ich muss sagen das
gefällt mir sehr sehr gut vor allem muss
ich auch sagen es hat mir so spaß
gemacht wirklich das war wirklich wenn
ich so auf die letzte news zurückblicke
mit abstand das lustigste
unterhaltsamste auch für mich selber ich
hoffe euch ganz genauso gefallen gibt
noch nach oben schreibt weitere ideen
dafür in die kommentare
haut rein check kann man beides zu knapp
30 alex w da geht es jetzt wieder
richtig los ich habe nämlich jemanden
mit dem ich jetzt zusammenarbeit für
mein instagram account da kommen immer
coole fotos jeden tag und ja es lohnt
sich rein abonniert auch gern youtube
channel chanel genau so gut mache mein
youtube channel